à une éventuelle primaire de la droite à
laquelle eric zemmour se verrait
peut-être bien participer alors que
l'essayiste on n'est toujours pas
officiellement candidat ses équipes
seraient en train d'étudier la
possibilité de participer à cette
primaire de la droite et du centre selon
une étude aux docks sap pour loeb s'il
réunit désormais 10% d'intentions de
vote une dynamique dont pâtit marine le
pen qui a relancé aujourd'hui sa
campagne sur le terrain à orange à metz
en moselle
alors la primaire de la droite deux
options qui émerge de la grande enquête
lancée par les républicains auprès de
son électorat pour savoir comment
désigner son candidat à la
présidentielle et les sympathisants sont
plutôt partisan d'un congrès au lieu
d'une grande primaire ouverte d'autant
qu'elle exhibe on serait donc tenté de
s'y inviter comme on vient de le dire
alors la droite se fait-elle et morizet
at elle les moyens de remporter cette
élection présidentielle c'est l'objet de
notre décryptage ce soit
avec nous pour en parler stéphane rozès
politologue président de cap vous êtes
également enseignant à hec et
sciences-po bonsoir stéphane rozès merci
d'être avec nous à vos côtés jean
frédéric poisson vous êtes le président
du parti via la voix du peuple à
candidat à la primaire de la droite en
2017 un processus donc que vous
connaissez très bien bonsoir à vous un
jean frédéric poisson donc casse-tête
ans alors un petit peu de vérité ce
week-end chez les républicains deux
options le congrès et les primaires
ouvertes 1 que refuse à tout prix à
xavier bertrand un congrès clairement
stéphane rozès lui serait plus favorable
à xavier bertrand qui on le rappeler est
un petit bol favori en tout cas des des
sondages en ce jour oui xavier bertrand
est légèrement favori effectivement
c'est lui serait favorable dans la
mesure où des pins dans une posture un
peu gaullienne selon laquelle une
présidentielle c'est la rencontre
directe entre le candidat et le peuple
dav écarté l'idée d'une primaire
néanmoins il a besoin du soutien du
parti républicain et donc du coup
ils auraient au travers de cette option
au fond mais ça voudrait dire ralliement
du parti républicain à sa candidature il
aurait le beurre et l'argent du beurre
alors on va voir ce que vont décider
les militants les choses sont un peu
ouverte et puis il ya eric zemmour qui
arrivent et qui fait un peu turbuler le
système bien enfin le système
effectivement de désignation et la
droite
parler de cette hypothèse zemmour vous
êtes vous jean françois poisson
jean-frédéric pardon comme poisson le
plus ancien candidat à la primaire de
2017 vous regrettez vous reviendriez
l'absence de primaires ouvertes cette
fois ci le parti est trop frileux selon
vous
franchement ce n'est plus tout à fait
mon problème si j'ose dire
mais je crois que il y a quelque chose
de faux c'est dans l'analyse que
j'entends chez ceux des républicains qui
s'opposent à la primaire il semble faire
reposer ce qu'ils considèrent comme un
échec de la primaire de 2016 la faute
sur la forme même discutant et je ne
partage pas cette idée je pense que si
d'abord la primaire n'a pas échoué
puisque elle a désigné un candidat qui
étaient largement majoritaires c'était
françois fillon certes avec un projet
politique peut être un peu trop libérale
par rapport à l'état de l'opinion ce qui
lui a joué quelques tours
d après d'ailleurs la sortie était de
primaires dès novembre et décembre 2016
mais je crois que nous sommes dans un
contexte où l'opinion publique les
français ont besoin d'être consultés ils
le disent les gilet jaune m'ont dit avec
une ride référendum d'initiative
citoyenne sur les ronds-points la gauche
n'avait considéré comme une forme de
tradition la démocratie participative
qui est portée dès 2007 par madame royal
enfin on sent bien que il ya cette
volonté de participer davantage aux
décisions et d'un autre côté on constate
une forte de traumatismes des militants
républicains chez beaucoup d'entre eux
sur le fait qu' une primaire au fond
leur ferait connaître à nouveau les
chèques de 2016 moi je n'ai franchement
pas d'idée sur cette question je pense
que la primaire en tant que tel
un intérêt je pense qu'elle n'est pas
dans la culture de la droite c'est ça
que je crois surtout il ya chez dans la
gauche historiquement une capacité une
habitude d'opérer des synthèses même
entre des positions qui sont très
opposées dans la nuit qui suit la
présentation d'émotion on sait bien que
au congrès du parti socialiste d'abus et
une négociation d'échangés que le
lendemain un chef et des signes tout le
monde se remet sur le nez le lendemain
matin à partir du lundi 8 heures c'est
une affaire entendue mais en attendant
il ya un projet politique un chef la
droite c'est mal faire ça et parce que
je pense que elle elle perd de vue cette
idée simple qui correspond je crois à
l'état de la france que et bien les
fondamentaux sur lesquels la droite est
assise idéologiquement depuis très
longtemps ses fondamentaux ont vacillé
au moins dans la tête de l'opinion il
n'est pas vrai que la france est
indépendante toujours il n'est pas vrai
que la famille demeure le socle l'a dit
social dans son ensemble il n'est pas
vrai de dire que les institutions sont
stables et pérennes tout ça est
questionné désarmé par l'opinion il faut
donc que la droite se réapproprie l'état
de l'opinion qu'elles repartent à la
conquête pédagogique de l'opinion ça ne
se fait pas sans la consulter donc je
crois que je termine en une phrase
pardon j'ai été un peu long au fond le
le problème n'est pas tant de savoir
s'il faut une primaire ou non le
problème est de savoir quel est le mode
de désignation qui correspond le mieux
aujourd'hui pas seulement à l'état de
l'opinion publique et à sa demande mais
aussi à l'étape politique du pays et ce
à quoi je crois les républicains ont du
mal à répondre alors la fameuse
hypothèse zemmour donc on ferme du
figaro nous dit que les proches de
zemmour aimerait bien le voir s'inviter
dans cette primaire on entend déjà
christian jacob et gérard larcher dira
non non il n'a pas sa place ici
clairement stéphane rozès est ce que
eric zemmour aujourd'hui est de droite
républicaine ce qu'il aurait sa place
dans une éventuelle primaire de la
droite et du centre
il concerne le parti républicain
s'est essayée dirigeants les militants
de répondre mais eric zemmour au fond
dans son diagnostic
du malheur français
aussi entre une approche souverainiste
et identite' ariste de ce point de vue
là il ne serait pas illégitime ou en
tout cas au sein du parti républicain
on parle moins possible de zemmour bedek
et micros sont pas là on ne parle pour
l'heure que de ça et notamment chez les
jeunes du parti républicain il un succès
certain au feu il semble sortir la
droite de ses divisions par par
l'extérieur pour tout un tas
d'électeurs alors les sondages disent
qu'il prend au rassemblement national à
marine le pen ainsi 10% même si il prend
à droite est offert dans l'idée qu'il
pourrait
régénérer et finalement obligé les
formations de droit d'être à l'écouté du
pays à partir d'un diagnostic
et c'est l'abbé bertrand doit faire très
attention
il ne doit pas apparaître dorénavant au
fond comme si nyon en fonction de ces
rapports ad les dirigeants politiques du
parti
républicain
zemmour se réclame ou si du général de
mme o'neill aurait à mon avis sans
problème
250 parrainage et la pression va être
forte pas seulement ce week end mais
après si eric zemmour devais y aller sur
la droite traditionnelle
alors jean frédéric poisson vos attaques
comme d'avant pour la présidentielle de
2000 22 aussi vous faites un tweet un
petit peu sibyllin aujourd'hui on va le
regarder avant de vous de nous demander
l'explication
retrait de ma candidature présidentielle
2022 il soutient à 7 eghezée moore s'il
se présente ce serait possible si alors
jean frédéric poisson vous vous
proposait d'apporter votre soutien à
eric zemmour sous certaines conditions
ces trois petits points qui font la
différence alors lesquels ce soir
finissez votre tweet
de conditions que j'ai précisé dans un
communiqué puis c'est nos confrères de
sud radio ailière
première condition que le projet qu'il
présente aux français s'infléchissent de
manière très sensible dans le sens clair
de la prise en compte de la fragilité
des fragilités connaissent les français
tout le monde peut comprendre qu'un
certain nombre de nos compatriotes sont
très inquiets de voir la france se
déliter se diluer avec une crainte de
disparition notre mode de vie notre
modèle social de notre culture par
endroit toute souveraineté c'est déjà
assez largement fait et ça inquiète une
bonne partie de l'opinion publique la
maîtrise des flux migratoires la lutte
contre l'immigration et le
rétablissement de notre identité sont
des choses nécessaires à faire pour
répondre à cette inquiétude mais ça ne
suffit pas car toutes ces inquiétudes ne
sont pas de nature culturelle ou
souveraine il ya des fragilités social
qu'il faut soigner je pense qu'il est
indispensable si on veut redresser le
pays et faire en sorte que les français
aillent mieux puisque ce savoureux cette
dimension sociale doit être intégré dans
son projet et pour l'instant on a va mal
ou peu mais il reste encore beaucoup de
réponses apportées qui la deuxième
condition vient d'être esquissé par par
monsieur rozès il ya quelques instants
au fond je pense que la lecture que fait
le parti des républicains sur l'état de
la france est incomplète
ce qui me fait dire c'est la nature des
solutions qui la porte ou que les
candidats à porte en général c'est à
dire plutôt des réponses soient plutôt
de marketing soit de gestion mais ça ne
suffit pas la france n'est pas seulement
mal géré la france ne va pas bien elle
est profondément marqué par la violence
par les fragilités et ce ne sont pas des
réponses techniques qui permettent de
régler ce genre de problème ce sont des
réponses politiques et c'est la raison
pour laquelle je pense que celui qui
acceptera l'idée que cette réponse
politique est capable de donner
l'impulsion à la refondation d'une
droite qui serait attentive à cette
dimension politique se il a de très
fortes chances non seulement de bien
figurer à l'élection les également de
l'emporter donc c'est pour ça que
j'appelle eric zemmour a à réfléchir
profondément à l'idée d'un rassemblement
de ce qui serait une confédération de
tous les mouvements qui sont attachés à
cette secte ur et qui sont grosso modo
des mouvements conservateurs sociaux
dans leur inspiration si ces deux
conditions sont réunies
d'abord le fait que la fragilité que
subissent bon nombre des français
d'aujourd'hui est prise en compte réelle
non dans son projet politique et
deuxièmement qu'il est d'accord pour
impulser ce projet confédéral de
reconstitution d'une droite
conservatrice et social alors je ferai
le constat que quelqu'un qui porte le
même projet politique que moi est mieux
placé que moi est dans la droite ligne
de ce que je porte depuis quelques
années si quelqu'un est mieux placé que
moi et portent le même projet que moi je
n'ai pas de raison d'être candidat
contre lui je n'ai d'ailleurs pas de
raison tout court d'être candidat et
donc j'apporterai mon soutien ma pierre
à cet édifice et j'y mettrai toute mon
énergie en tout cas son nom est sur
beaucoup de lèvres comme l'a expliqué
stéphane rozès tout à l'heure marine le
pen a notamment qui a lancé sa campagne
interrogé sur justement cette hypothèse
et moore écoutez la réponse là l'ex
présidente du rassemblement national
candidate à la présidentielle
j'ai vu beaucoup de candidats suscité un
intérêt médiatique
en réalité lorsque l'intérêt médiatique
s'essouffle les candidatures de ces
personnalités elle-même s'essouffle à
une candidature médiatique eric zemmour
quelle est votre opinion stéphane rozès
ça va faire puis parce que c'est vrai
que c'est sur toutes les lèvres les
médias
oui bien sûr mais de toute façon je fais
partie des rares politologue qui pensent
non pas que les médias ou la classe
politique impose ou pays quoi que ce
soit mais que celle inverse que c'est le
rapport du pays au réel l'évolution de
ces perceptions à partir de son
imaginaire et de ses fondamentaux qui
fait assez rapidement les médias et plus
lentement le système politique prend en
compte ce qui émerge un hameau me
succède essayiste d'eric zemmour en
termes d'audience de vente de livre
rencontre un sentiment plus anciens
d'une dépression française d'un
déclassement de notre modèle le fait que
les deux tiers des français estiment
depuis cinq ans qui ne s'en sentent ou
en france comme chez eux le fait que les
deux tiers des françaises
l'appel des généraux dans à l'heure
actuelle ne les voyant pas comme eux
sont peut-être certains d'entre eux des
putschistes extrême droite mais plutôt
comme des lanceurs d'alert
montre mes estimations
d'une l'homme malheur
ressentie par défoncer très divers de
droite de gauche de conditions sociales
différentes que la chatterie des défis
des jaunes soutenues par les deux tiers
des français
expriment moi j'ai toujours analyser ça
comme une demande de retour de
l'autorité politique et de la
souveraineté comme chatterie qui
appartient de la question fiscale me
retourne et devoirs du souverain bien
tout ce contexte fait que eric zemmour
alors qu'au départ sans nutini pensait
par est porté par quelque chose est dit
finalement pourquoi je n'irai pas
d'autant que puisque vous parlez de
marine le pen son analyse est à tort ou
à raison je pense que ça peut se
discuter
son analyse est que au fond marine le
pen comme une leader ne peut plus porter
quoi que ce soit parce qu'au fond selon
lui
dans sa façon d'être de fer d'analyser
les régionales les cantonales
elle n'aurait plus la dynamique qu'elle
avait alors là où je rejoins monsieur
poisson
c'est qu il faudra qu eric zemmour
précise ses griefs c'est à dire qu'il ya
une petite citation chérif ghemmour
entre une réponse souverainiste et
identitarisme bizarrement marie le pen a
fait un mouvement brownien ce dernier a
nié et il faut faire la démonstration
pourrir exim our que silva à la
présidentielle s'est pas seulement pour
témoigner pas seulement dias il va pas
pas seulement dire pourquoi la france
fut tout tomber mais de dire hier
quelque chose de possible
hélas sa demande effectivement par eric
zemmour mais c'est normal que tout ça
soit de son point de vue en construction
un certain nombre de précisions passez y
compris dans ses critiques de marine le
pen on ne sait pas très bien si la
critique sur ce problème de leadership
ou sur une orientation qu'il considérait
comme au fond trop social trop
républicaine trop nationale bref tout ça
promet des clarifications mais
clairement eric zemmour
arnaud montebourg sont les deux
nouveautés de cette présidentielle parce
que
explicitement encore plus que marine le
pen dorénavant une pose la question de
l'avenir de notre modèle pour l'heure
est réglée moanda une réponse plutôt
identite' ariste arnaud montebourg
plutôt souverainiste social mais je
pense personnellement que le sujet de la
présidence elle sera le retour de la
souveraineté de la nation et remettre
l'état au service de la nation
jean-frédéric passant le mois de la fin
pour vous et effectivement eric zemmour
profitent de de cet espace conte on lui
laisse
aller pense j'ajoute à ce que vient de
dire stéphane rozès une enquête qui
sorti il ya quelques jours et qui disait
que près de deux tiers des français
considère que la france est en déclin ce
qui rejoint la longue liste des sondages
que nous si rozès a lui même rappelé sur
ce sentiment d'évitement je crois que
l'on peut lire effectivement si on va un
peu vite l'émergence d'eric zemmour
comme quelque chose qui ne relève que de
la qualité des audiences qui de grâce
semble sur ses news ce serait aller un
peu vite en besogne car je partage
parfaitement la vie de monsieur rozès sa
position sa fidélité à la tradition de
l'histoire française au fond dont on
peut discuter de lecture sur certains
des épisodes mais globalement sa
filiation très clair dans la tradition
de l'histoire française rejoint quelque
chose qui est attendu par d'opinion est
ce que ce rapport d'une certaine manière
il perçoit les militants de cette
fidélité parce que personne d'autre ne
l'exercent les personne d'autre ne fait
cet exercice de référence ce qui a fait
notre passé et glorieux ou moins
glorieux par ailleurs je mon sentiment
c'est que
d'une certaine manière l'espace est
ouvert je vois bien les réactions de m
le pen aujourd'hui pourquoi parce que
parmi les causes du déclin de la france
on peut imaginer que en tout cas ceux
qui sont comme moi donc ce que là je
réponds pour moi pas pour monsieur
zemmour bien sûr
pour moi des très grands critiques est
très constant critique de la
construction européenne que nous avons
sous les yeux le fait que le
rassemblement national est abandonnée
successivement ces derniers mois l'idée
de sortir de schengen l'idée de sortir
bako européenne des droits de l'homme
renoncer absolument à toute idée de
frais xi et abandonner la volonté de
réformer l'euro c'est un noyau complète
son électorat qui s'emballe là pour le
coup il ya une forme d'abandon ce qui a
fait de la tradition historique du
rassemblement national qui s'est
largement constitué sur les premiers
scrutins européens des années 80 qui a
fait d'ailleurs du quelques-uns des
succès électoraux spectaculaire du parti
alors dirigé par son père donc
effectivement
se retrouve orphelin de la même manière
que se retrouve orphelin chez les
républicains les militants qui attendent
une certaine fermeté je fais référence à
ce que disait ne se reconnaissent à
l'instant sur l'autorité de l'état de la
même façon se retrouve au sein du
rassemblement national ce qui était
attachée une attitude extrêmement ferme
presque rigide parfois à l'égard de la
construction européenne et de ses
conséquences et au milieu de ça il y à
la détresse des français que globalement
personne de traite et pour nuancer un
peu s'il me le permet la conclusion de
stéphane rozès à l'instant je pense que
prioritairement effectivement il ya une
demande de retour à l'autorité très
clair mais ce sentiment que l'autorité
de l'état ne fait pas tout et que si on
ne redonne pas du pouvoir aux acteurs
locaux alors on ne traitera pas comme il
faut les questions qui sont liées à la
solidarité et à l'entr'aide j'ai
l'impression tout de même s'ils ont la
conviction que ce besoin d'entraidé très
très important en deux corps social
français aujourd'hui j'espère que eric
zemmour 2 comprendra et j'attends sa
réponse sur ce point puisque je lui ai
posé très clairement cette question
merci beaucoup en tout cas tous les deux
stéphane rozès jean frédéric poisson
d'avoir été avec nous avoir apporté
votre analyse